this camera boasts 36 lenses giving the
photographer a bird's eye view a company
representative shows off the new models
power once it's a loft it takes a
360-degree panorama picture at this
year's Aoife startups are showing the
world the future of photography this
handheld camera takes three-dimensional
pictures that opens up a whole new world
of photographic possibilities coupled
with the right 3d printer it can make
miniature plastic models of people for
instance the camera is expected to hit
the market over the next few weeks and
is selling for just under 300 euros the
required printer will set you back a bit
more though there are also professional
attachments for smartphones which can
record broadcast quality video and to
make sure your adventure footage doesn't
shake too much they're steady sticks for
the action cam all these new ideas are
emerging from young innovative startups
that caught the eyes of investors years
ago venture capitalists have too much
money right now and they're just making
it rain on to startups so there's just a
lot of startups coming up right now that
are just looking for money and they have
a lot of it so I think maybe five
percent of them will actually succeed
but if they succeed they're gonna make a
big these are still niche products but
who knows maybe the next Aoife will
bring the global game changer in
consumer electronics that the world's
been waiting for